our ongoing series a more perfect union
aims to show what unites us as Americans
is far greater than what divides us this
morning special correspondent James
Brown introduces us to an unassuming NFL
star who avoids the limelight he spent
most of his life putting his time heart
soul and money into helping kids in
underserved communities here and abroad
JB good morning good morning Chris long
is in his tenth season and is currently
a playmaker on the high-flying
Philadelphia Eagles but with a simple
empathetic gesture of putting his hand
on the shoulder of teammate Malcolm
Jenkins that during the national anthem
earlier this season he took a step into
a spotlight that long has always avoided
for me my little gesture it had
everything to do with I thought what was
right you're standing but you have your
hand on your teammates shoulder to
signify what I'd like to stand because
it's something that would signify what I
hope America can be I certainly
empathize with the form of protest to
draw attention to inequities in this
country and I think you know it's not
about the knee it's what you do in your
community and walking the walk Chris
long does walk the walk after his small
gesture he made a big one by donating
the last 10 games salary checks of his 1
million dollar salary to education
charities in st. Louis Boston and
Philadelphia the three NFL cities where
he played in his decade-long career
where did you get the itching to be
involved in charitable endeavors well
for me
JB it was having two great parents as
you know my mother's been really
instrumental and raised a lot of money
through the Boys and Girls Club in my
hometown and my dad obviously who played
13 years in the NFL he grew up with a
lot less than I had and he gave me what
what he didn't have through football so
I feel like it's my responsibility with
this platform to give back Chris is the
oldest of three sons of hall-of-famer
Howie long and his wife Diane the Long's
raised their boys in Charlottesville
Virginia
the
family has for 20 years been wonderful
it's not just Howie and Diane it's it's
Kyle it's Chris it's young Howie so
we're very thankful for the whole family
James Pierce is the CEO of the Boys &
Girls Club of central Virginia he says
Chris and his wife Megan have continued
the tradition giving money but also time
Chris said to me I'd really like to come
by and you know spend some time with the
kids so I'm counting on 15 or 20 minutes
two and a half hours later you know this
picture was taken last August white
masters held a March that ended in
tragedy right here in downtown
Charlottesville for Chris long it fueled
a desire to do even more in his hometown
and beyond when you see it firsthand you
know it was very real I mean they were
literally in our home and I don't think
it's representative of Charlottesville
Chris and Megan met at the University of
Virginia he starred in football and she
in La Crosse they planned to raise their
son Waylon in Charlottesville it wakes
you up do you think you're awake - all
these things anyways but it heightens
your your sense of anger and your sense
of man we got to fix some things about
this country with that in mind long uses
first six games salary checks to
establish two full scholarships for Boys
and Girls Club kids to attend his old
prep school st. Anne's Belfield that's
right
he's playing for free this season his
high school coach John Blake is not
surprised he has always been one that's
gonna stand up for what he feels is
right he's also gonna stand up for the
little guy I think he's a big believer
in actions speak louder than words and
his actions now are taking it to that
next level I just think we've been lucky
and I want to give people the
opportunities that I had and now as
being parents we talk about this all the
time
I couldn't imagine our son Waylon not
having you know everything he's gonna
have you know you you meet a kid and now
that we're parents I feel like you're
gonna see your kid in that kid
several years ago Chris told his mom and
dad that he wanted to make a difference
in his life and boy has he in addition
to his education initiatives here in
America his charity called water boys
has raised 1.6 million dollars to build
29 solar-powered wells that deliver
much-needed clean water to communities
in East Africa all right James Ron I
love that graphic go long because don't
you think his mom and dad are proud and
just a message that he's sending to his
own son yeah absolutely right and that's
that's a lot to donate your salary for
the you know well and also his time and
you know in other ways it's not just
writing the check he's living he's
walking it that's the message to the son
two hours later he was there